we have the power now for the first time
in the history of our species
to harness artificial intelligence to
help us really flourish
and help bring out the best in our
Humanity
rather than the worst of it
to help us have really fulfilling
experiences that feel truly meaningful
and you and I shouldn't sit here and
dictate the future Generations what they
will be let them figure it out but let's
give them a chance to live and and not
foreclose all these possibilities for
them by just messing things up right
well for that we'll have to solve the AI
safety problem I just it would be nice
if we can link on exploring that a
little bit so one interesting way to
enter that discussion is uh you tweeted
and Elon replied you tweeted let's not
just focus on whether gpt4 will do more
harm or good on the job market but also
whether it's coding skills will hasten
the arrival of super intelligence that's
something we've been talking about right
so Elon proposed one thing in the reply
saying maximum truth seeking is my best
guess for AI safety can you maybe uh
Steel Man the case for this uh since
this objective function of Truth and uh
maybe an argument against it in general
what are your different ideas to start
approaching the solution to AI safety I
didn't see that reply actually oh
interesting all right so but I really
resonate with it because
AI is not evil it caused people around
the world to hate each other much more
but that's because we made it in a
certain way it's a tool we can use it
for great things and bad things and we
could just as well have ai systems and
this is this is part of my vision for
Success here
truth seeking AI that really brings us
together again you know why do people
hate each other so much between
countries and within countries it's
because
these have totally different versions of
the truth right
if they all have the same truth that
they trusted for good reason because
they could check it and verify it and
not have to believe in some
self-proclaimed Authority right
they wouldn't be as nearly as much hate
there'd be a lot more understanding
instead and uh
this is
I think something AI can help enormously
with
for example
a little baby step in this direction is
this website called metaculous where
People BET and make predictions not for
money but just for their own reputation
and it's kind of funny actually you
treat the humans like you treat AI as
you have a loss function where they get
penalized if they're super confident on
something and then the opposite happens
yeah
whereas if you're kind of humble and
then you're like I think it's 51 chance
this is going to happen and then the
other happens you don't get penalized
much and
and what you can see is that some people
are much better at predicting than
others they've earned your trusts right
one project that I'm working on right
now is the outgrowth to improve the news
Foundation together the metaculous focus
is seeing if we can really scale this up
a lot with more powerful AI because I
would love it I would love for there to
be like a really powerful truth seeking
system
where
that is trustworthy because it keeps
being right about stuff and people who
come to it and
maybe look at its latest trust ranking
of different pundits and newspapers Etc
if they want to know why some someone
got a low score they can click on it and
see all the predictions that they
actually made and how they turned out
you know this is how we do it in science
you trust scientists like Einstein who
said something everybody thought was
and turned out to be right
you get a lot of trust Point than he did
it multiple times even
uh
I think AI has the power to really heal
a lot of the Rifts we're seeing by
creating Trust Systems
we it has to get away from this idea
today with some fact checking sites
which might themselves have an agenda
and you just trust it because of its
reputation
you want to have it so this so these
sort of systems they are in their trust
and that's completely transparent
this I think would actually help a lot
uh that can I think help heal the very
dysfunctional conversation that Humanity
has about how it's going to deal with
all its
biggest challenges in in the world today
and then uh
enter on the technical side you know
another common sort of Gloom
comment I get from people are saying
we're just screwed there's no hope is
well things like gpt4 are way too
complicated for a human to ever
understand and prove that they can be
trustworthy they're forgetting that AI
can help us prove that things work right
yeah and and there's this very
fundamental fact that in math it's much
harder to come up with a proof than it
is to verify that the proof is correct
you can actually write a little proof
checking code it's quite short
but you can assume and understand and
then it can check the most monstrously
long proof ever generated even by a
computer and say yeah this is valid
so so right now
we we have um
this uh
this approach with virus checking
software that it looks to see if there's
something you should not trust it and if
it can prove to itself that you should
not trust that code it warns you right
when did you flip this around
and this is an idea I should give credit
to Steve I'm 100 for
so that it will only run the code if it
can prove instead of not running it if
it can prove that it's not trustworthy
if it will only run and if it can prove
that it's trustworthy so it asks the
code it prove to me that you're going to
do what you say you're going to do
and and it gives you this proof
and you're a little proof that you can
check it now you can actually trust
an AI That's much more intelligent than
you are right
because you it's it's problem to come up
with this proof that you could never
have found that you should trust it so
this is the interesting point I I agree
with you but this is where Eliezer
yakowski might disagree with you his
claim not with you but with this idea
is his claim is super intelligent AI
would be able to know how to lie to you
with such a proof
I'll Delight to you and give me a proof
that I'm gonna think is correct yeah so
but it's not me it's lying to that's the
trick my proof checker
which is a piece of code so his general
idea is a super intelligent system
can lie to a dumber proof checker
so you're going to have as a system
becomes more and more intelligent
there's going to be a threshold
or a super intelligence system will be
able to effectively lie just slightly
Dumber AGI system uh like there's a
threat like he really focuses on this
weak AGI the strong AGI jump with a
strong AGI can make all the weak as you
guys think that it's just one of them
but it's no longer that
and that leap is when it runs away yeah
I I don't buy that argument I think no
matter how super intelligent an AI is
it's never going to be able to prove to
me that they're only finitely many
primes for example
just it just can't and and um it can try
to snow Me by making up all sorts of new
weird rules of deduction
that
and say trust me you know
the way your proof Checker work is too
limited and we have this new hyper map
and it's true but then I would I would
just uh take the attitude okay I'm gonna
forfeit some of these this supposedly
super cool technology so I'm only going
to go with the ones that I can prove in
my own trusted proof gesture then I
don't I think it's fine there's still of
course
this is not something anyone has
successfully implemented at this point
but I think it I just give it as an
example of hope we don't have to do all
the work ourselves right this is exactly
the sort of very boring and tedious task
that is perfect to Outsource to an AI
and this is a way in which less powerful
and less intelligent agents like us can
actually
continue to control and Trust more
powerful ones so build AGI systems that
help us defend against other AGI systems
well for starters
begin with a simple problem of just
making sure that the system that you own
or that's supposed to be loyal to you
has to prove to itself that it's always
going to do the things that you actually
wanted to do right and if it can't prove
it maybe it's still going to do it but
you won't run it so you just forfeit
some aspects of all the cool things AI
can do I I bet your dollars of donuts
you can still do some incredibly cool
stuff for you yeah there are there are
other things too that we shouldn't sweep
under the rug like not every human
agrees on exactly where what direction
we should go with Humanity right yes
and you've talked a lot about the
geopolitical things on this on on your
podcast to this effect you know but
I think that shouldn't distract us from
the fact that there are actually a lot
of things that everybody in the world
virtually agrees on that hey you know
like having no humans on the planet
in a in a near future ah let's not do
that right you looked at something like
the United Nations sustainable
development goals some of them are quite
ambitious and uh basically all the
countries agree U.S China Russia Ukraine
they all agree so instead of quibbling
about the little things we don't agree
on let's start with the things we do
with Beyond and and get them done
instead of being so distracted by all
these things we disagree on
that Morlock wins because
frankly
molok going wild now it feels like a war
on Life playing out in front of our eyes
if you if you just look at it from space
you know we're on this planet
beautiful vibrant ecosystem now we start
chopping down
big parts of it even though nobody most
people thought that was a bad idea
always start doing ocean acidification
wiping out all sorts of species oh now
we have all these close calls we almost
had a nuclear war and we're replacing
more and more of the biosphere with
non-living things we're also replacing
in our social lives a lot of the things
which were so valuable to humanity a lot
of social interactions now are replaced
by people staring into their rectangles
right and I
I'm not a psychologist I'm out of my
depth here but I suspect that part of
the reason why teen suicide and suicide
in general in the US that
record-breaking levels is actually
caused by
again and so AI Technologies and social
media making people spend less time with
with actually and actually just human
interaction we've all seen
a bunch of good looking people in
restaurants staring into the rectangles
instead of looking at each other's eyes
right
so that's also a part of the war in life
that that we're we're replacing so many
really life-affirming things
by technology we're we're putting
technology between us
the the technology that was supposed to
connect us is actually distancing us
ourselves from each other and um
and oh and then we're giving ever more
power to things which are not alive
these large corporations are not living
things right they're just maximizing
profit
there
I want to win them more in life I I
think we humans together with all our
fellow living things on this planet will
be better off if we can
remain in control over the non-living
things and make sure that they they work
for us I really think it can be done
can you just Linger on this uh maybe
high level philosophical disagreement
with Eliezer yadkowski
bye in this the hope you're stating so
he is very sure
he puts a very high probability
very close to one depending on the day
he puts it at one uh that AI is going to
kill humans
that there's just he does not see a
trajectory which it doesn't end up with
that conclusion what uh which trajectory
do you see that doesn't end up there and
maybe can you can you see the point he's
making
and and can you also see a way out
mm-hmm
first of all I tremendously respect
Elias yukowski and his his thinking
second I do share his view that there's
a pretty large chance that we're not
going to make it as humans there won't
be any humans on the planet
and not a distant future and that makes
me very sad you know we just had a
little baby and I keep asking myself you
know is um
how old is he even gonna get you know
and and um I asked myself okay
it feels I said to my wife recently it
feels a little bit like I was just
diagnosed with some sort of
cancer which has some you know risk of
of dying from in some risk of surviving
you know
uh
except this is the kind of cancer which
will kill all of humanity so I
completely take seriously his
um his concerns
I think um
but I don't absolutely don't think it's
hopeless I think um
there is a there is a
first of all a lot of momentum now
for the first time actually since the
many many years that have passed since
since I and many others started warm
warning about this I feel
most people are getting it now
I
I I uh
I was just talking
to this guy in the gas station their
house the other day my
and he's like
I think we're getting replaced
and then I think in it so that's
positive that they're finally we're
finally seeing this reaction which is
the first step towards solving the
problem uh second uh I really think that
this this vision of only running ai's
really if the stakes are really high
they can prove to us that they're safe
it's really just virus checking in
Reverse again I I think it's
scientifically doable
I don't think it's hopeless um
we might have to Forfeit some of the
technology that we could get if we were
putting Blind Faith in our AIS but we're
still going to get amazing stuff do you
envision a process with the proof
Checker like something like gpt4 GPT 5
will go through a process no rigorous no
obligation no I think it's hopeless
that's like trying to prove there about
five spaghetti
okay what I think well how the the whole
the vision I have for success is instead
that you know just like we human beings
were able to look at our brains and and
they still out the key knowledge Galileo
when his dad threw him an apple when he
was a kid he was able to catch it
because his brain could in this funny
spaghetti kind of way you know predict
how parabolos are going to move his
konaman system one right but then he got
older and it's like wait
this is a parabola it's it's y equals x
squared I can distill this knowledge out
and today you can easily program it into
a computer and it can simulate not just
that but how to get to Mars and so on
right I Envision a similar process where
we use the the amazing learning power of
neural networks
to discover the knowledge in the first
place but we don't stop with a black box
and and use that we then do a second
round of AI where we use automated
systems to extract out the knowledge and
see what is it what are the insights
it's had okay and it's
and then we we put that knowledge into a
completely different kind of um
architecture programming language or
whatever that's that's made in a way
that it can be both really efficient and
also
is more amenable to very formal
verification
that's that's my vision I'm not saying
sitting here saying I'm confident 100
sure that it's going to work you know
but I don't think it's a chance it's
certainly not zero either and it will
certainly be possible to do for a lot of
really cool AI applications that we're
not using now so we can have a lot of
the fun that we're excited about
if we if we do this we're going to need
a little bit of time
that's why it's good to pause and put in
place requirements
one more thing also I I think
you know someone might think well zero
percent chance we're gonna survive let's
just give up right that's very dangerous
because there's no more guaranteed way
it's a fail than to convince yourself
that it's impossible and not try
you know any if you you know when you
study history in military history the
first thing you learn is that that's
how you do psychological warfare you
persuade the other side that it's
hopeless so they don't even fight
and then then of course you win right
let's not do this uh psychological
warfare on ourselves and say there's 100
probability we're all gonna we're all
screwed anyway
it's sadly I I do get that a little bit
sometimes from from uh some young people
who are like so convinced that we're all
screwed that they're like I'm just gonna
play game play computer games and do
drugs and because we're screwed anyway
right
it's important
to keep the hope alive because it
actually has a causal impact on making
it makes it more likely that we're going
to succeed it seems like the people that
actually build solutions to a problem
seemingly impossible to solve problems
are the ones that believe yeah they're
the ones who were the optimists yeah and
it's like uh it seems like there's some
fundamental law to the universe where
fake it till you make it kind of works
like believe it's possible and it
becomes possible yeah was it Henry Ford
who said that
if you can if you tell yourself that
it's impossible it is
so let's not make that mistake yeah and
this is a big mistake Society is making
or I think all in all everybody's so
gloomy and the media are also very
biased towards if it bleeds it bleeds
and Bloom and doom right so
um
most
visions of the future we have or or a
dystopian which really demotivates
people we want to really really focus on
the upside also to give people the
willingness to fight for it
and um
for AI you and I mostly talked about
Gloom here again but let's not remember
not forget that you know
we have probably both lost
someone we really care about some
disease that we were told was incurable
well it's not there's no law of physics
saying they have to die of that cancer
or whatever of course you can cure it
and there's so many other things where
that we with our human intelligence have
also failed to solve on this planet
which AI could also very much help us
with right so if we can get this right
just be a little more chill and slow
down a little bit till we get it right
it's mind-blowing how awesome our future
can be right we talked a lot about stuff
on Earth it can be great
but even if you really get ambitious and
look up at the skies right there's no
reason we have to be stuck on this
planet for the rest of um
the remain for billions of years to come
we totally understand now that laws of
physics let life spread out into space
to other solar systems to other galaxies
and flourish for billions of billions of
years
and this to me is a very very hopeful
vision
that really motivates me to to fight
them and coming back in the end
something you talked about again you
know that's the struggle how the human
struggle is one of the things that also
really gives meaning to our lives if
there's ever been an epic struggle
this is it and isn't it even more epic
if you're the underdog
if most people are telling you this is
gonna fail it's impossible right and you
persist
and you succeed
and that's what we can do together as a
species on this one a lot of pundits are
ready to count this out
both in the battle to keep AI safe and
becoming multiple planetary species yeah
and they're they're the same challenge
if we can keep AI safe that's how we're
gonna get multi-planatory very
efficiently
I had some sort of technical questions
about how to get it right so one idea
uh that I'm not even sure what the right
answer is to is uh should systems like
gpt4 be open sourced in the whole arm
part can you make the can you see the
case for either
I think the answer right now is no
I think the answer early on was yes
so we could bring in the all the
wonderful great thought process of
everybody on this but asking should we
open source gpt4 now is just the same as
if you say well is it good should we
open source
um
you know how to build really small
nuclear weapons should we open source
how to make bio weapons uh should you
open source how to make um
a new virus that kills 90 of everybody
who gets it of course we shouldn't
so it's already that powerful
it's already that powerful that we have
to respect the power of the systems
we've built
the knowledge that you get
um
from open sourcing everything we do now
it might very well be powerful enough
that people looking at that
can use it to build the things that are
really threatening again let's get it
remember open AI is
dpt4 is a baby AI baby sort of baby
Proto almost a little bit AGI and
according to what Microsoft's recent
paper said right
it's not that they were scared of what
we're scared about is people taking that
who are
who might be a lot less responsible than
the company that made it right and uh
just going to town with it that's why
we want to
it's it's an information Hazard there
are many things which um you know are
not open sourced right now in society
for very good reason like how how do you
make
certain kind of very powerful toxins out
of stuff you can buy at Home Depot you
know you know you don't open source
those things for a reason
and this is really no different
so uh what I'm saying that I have to say
it feels in a bit weird but in a way a
bit weird to say it because MIT is like
the Cradle of the open source movement
and I love open source in general power
to the people let's say um
but um there's always gonna be some
stuff that you don't open source and you
know it's just like you don't open
source so we have a three-month-old baby
right when he gets a little bit older
we're not going to open source to him
all the most dangerous things he could
do in the house yeah right
but it does it's a weird feeling because
this is one of the first moments in
history where so there's a strong case
to be made not to open source software
this is when the software has become
yeah too dangerous yeah but it's not the
first time that we didn't want to open
source a technology technology yeah
is there something to be said about how
to get the release of such systems right
like gpt4 and gpt5
so open AI went through a pretty
rigorous effort for several months you
could say it could be longer but
nevertheless it's longer than you would
have expected of trying to test the
system to see like what are the ways
goes wrong to make it very difficult for
people well
somewhat difficult for people to ask
things how do I make a bomb for one
dollar
or how do I say I hate a certain group
on Twitter in a way that doesn't get me
blocked from Twitter banned from Twitter
those kinds of questions yes uh so you
basically use the system to do harm yeah
uh is there something you could say
about ideas you have it's just on
looking having thought about this
problem of AI safety how to release a
system how to test the systems when you
have them inside the company
yeah so
a lot of people say that the two biggest
risks from large language models are
it's spreading this information
harmful information the various types
and second being used for offensive
cyber weapon
design I think those are not the two
greatest threats they're very serious
threats and it's wonderful that people
are trying to mitigate them
it's a much bigger elephant in the room
is how is this it's going to disrupt our
economy in a huge way obviously and
maybe take away a lot of the most
meaningful jobs
uh and an even bigger one is the one we
spent so much time talking about here
that that
this
becomes the Bootloader for the more
powerful AI write code connected to the
internet manipulate humans yeah and
before we know it we have something else
which is not at all a large language
model it looks nothing like it but which
is way more intelligent and capable and
has goals
and that's the that's the elephant in
the room and and uh obviously no matter
how hard any of these companies have
tried and they that's not something
that's easy for them to verify with a
large language models and the only way
to be
really lower that risk a lot would be
to not let for example try not to never
let it read any code not train on that
and not put it into an API
and um
not
not give it access to so much
information about how to manipulate
humans
so but that doesn't mean you still can't
make a lot
a ton of money on them you know uh we're
gonna
just watch now this coming year right
Microsoft is rolling out the new uh
office suite where you go into Microsoft
Word and give it a prompt they did
writes the whole text for you and then
you edit it and then you're like oh give
me a PowerPoint version of this and it
makes it and now take the spreadsheet
and blah blah and you know all of those
things I think are you can debate the
economic impact of it and whether
Society is prepared to deal with this
disruption but those are not the things
which
that's not the elephant of the room that
keeps me awake at night for wiping out
Humanity
and
I think that's the biggest
misunderstanding we have a lot of people
think that we're scared of like
automatic spreadsheets that's not the
case that's not what Eliana was freaked
out about either
is there
in terms of the actual mechanism of how
AI might kill all humans
so something you've been outspoken about
you've talked about a lot is it
autonomous weapon systems
so the use of AI in war is that one of
the things that still you carry concern
for as these systems become more and
more powerful and carry concern for it
not that all humans are going to get
killed by slaughterbots but rather just
this uh express route into orwellian
dystopia where it becomes much easier
for very few to kill very many and
therefore it becomes very easy for very
few to dominate very many right
um
yeah if you want to know how I could
kill all people just ask yourself we
humans have driven a lot of species
extinct how do we do it
you know we were smarter than them
usually we didn't do it even
systematically by going around
one-on-one one after the other and
stepping on them or shooting them or
anything like that we just like chopped
down their habitat because we needed it
for something else
uh in some cases we did it by putting
more carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
because
of some reason that those animals didn't
even understand and now they're gone
right uh so if
um if you're in Ai and you just wanna
figure something out then you decide you
know we just really need them the space
here to build more compute facilities
you know
if that's the only goal it has you know
we are just the sort of accidental
roadkill along the way and you could
totally imagine yeah maybe this oxygen
is kind of annoying because it caused
more corrosion so let's get rid of the
oxygen
and good luck surviving after that you
know I I I'm not particularly concerned
that they would want to kill us just
because
that would be like
a goal in itself you know when we
've driven the number we've driven a
number of the elephant species extinct
right it wasn't because we didn't like
elephants
what the basic problem is you just don't
want to give you don't want to seed
control over your planet to some other
more intelligent entity that doesn't
share your goals it's that simple so
which brings us to another key challenge
which AI safety researchers have been
grappling with for a long time like how
do you make it AI
first of all understand our goals and
then adopt our goals and then retain
them as they get smarter right and um
all three of those are really hard right
like
a human child first they're just not
smart enough to understand our goals
they can't even talk
and then eventually they're teenagers
and understand our goals just fine but
they don't share yeah but there is
unfortunately a Magic's phase in the
Middle where they're smart enough to
understand our goals and malleable
enough that we can hopefully with good
parenting and teach them right from
wrong and instead good goal and still
good goals in them right and
so those are all tough challenges with
computers and then you know even if you
teach your kids good goals when they're
little they might outgrow them to and
that's a challenge for machines to keep
improving so these are a lot of hard
hard uh challenges we're up for but I
don't think any of them are
insurmountable
the fundamental reason why
Eliezer looked so depressed when I last
saw him was because he felt it just
wasn't enough time
there's just not enough time he was
hoping that Humanity was going to take
this threat more seriously so we would
have more time yeah and now we don't
have more time that's why the open
letter is calling for more time
but even with time the AI alignment
problem
seems to be really difficult oh yeah
but it's also the most worthy problem
the most important problem for Humanity
to ever solve because if we solve that
one Lex
that align the eye can help us solve all
the other problems because it seems like
it has to have constant humility
about his goal constantly questioned the
goal
because as you optimize towards a
particular goal and you start to achieve
it that's when you have the unintended
consequences all the things you
mentioned about so how do you enforce
and code a constant humility as your
ability become better and better and
better and better Stuart Professor
Stuart Russell at Berkeley who's also
one of the
driving forces behind this letter he uh
has a whole research program about this
I think of it as a humility exactly
although he calls it inverse
reinforcement learning and other nerdy
terms but it's about exactly that
instead of telling the AI here's this
goal go optimize the bejesus out of it
you tell it okay
do what I want you to do but I'm not
going to tell you right now what it is I
want you to do you need to figure it out
so then you give the incentive to be
very humble and keep asking you
questions along the way is this what you
really meant is this what you wanted and
oh this other thing I tried didn't work
seemed like it didn't work out right
should I try it differently
what's nice about this is it's not just
philosophical mumbo-jumbo it's theorems
and Technical work that with more time I
think it can make a lot of progress and
there are a lot of brilliant people now
working on AI safety and we're just not
we just need to give them a bit more
time but also not that many relatives to
the skill of the problem no way exactly
there should be
at least just like every University
worth its name has some cancer research
going on in its biology Department right
every University that's computer that
does computer science should have a real
effort in this area and it's nowhere
near that this is something I hope is
changing though thanks to the gpt4 right
so I I think
if there's a silver lining to um what's
happening here even though I think many
people would wish it would have been
rolled out more carefully is that this
might be the wake-up call
that Humanity needed
to really
stop the stop fantasizing about this
being 100 years off and stop fantasizing
about this being completely controllable
and predictable because
it's so obvious it's it's not
predictable you know why is it that open
that
I think it was GP chat GPT tried to
persuade um
a journalist
to divorce his wife you know it was not
because the the engineers had built it
so I was like
yeah let's put this in here and and
screw a little bit with people
they haven't predicted at all they built
a giant black box and
trained to predict the next word and got
all these emergent properties and oops
it did this you know
um
I I think this is a very powerful
wake-up call and now anyone watching
this is not scared I would encourage
them to just play a bit more with these
these tools they're out there now like
gpd4
and um
it's a wake-up calls first up once
you've woken up uh then gotta slow down
a little bit the risky stuff
to give a chance to all everyone's woken
up to to catch up with us on the safety
front you know what's interesting is you
know MIT
that's computer science but in general
but let's just even say computer science
curriculum
how does the computer science curriculum
change now you mentioned you mentioned
programming yeah like why would you be
when I was coming up programming is a
prestigious position like why would you
be dedicating crazy amounts of time to
become an excellent programmer like the
nature program is fundamentally changing
the nature of our entire education
system
is completely turned on its head has
anyone been able to like load that in
and like think about because it's really
turning I mean it's pretty English
professors or English teachers are
beginning to really freak out now yeah
right like to give an essay assignment
then they get back all this fantastic
Pros like this is the style of Hemingway
and then they realize they have to
completely rethink and even you know
just like we stopped teaching um
writing a script is that what you say in
English yeah handwritten yeah yeah when
when everybody started typing you know
like so much of what we teach our kids
today
yeah I mean that's
uh
everything is changing and it's
exchanging very it is it's changing very
quickly and so much of us understanding
how to deal with the big problems of the
world is through the education system
and if the education system is being
turned on its head then what what's next
it feels like having these kinds of
conversations is essential to try to
figure it out and everything's happening
so rapidly uh I don't think there's even
speaking of safety what the broad AI
safety defined I don't think most
universities have courses on AI safety
philosophy and like I I'm an educator
myself so it pains me to see this say
this but I feel our education right now
is the completely obsoleted
by what's happening you know you put a
kid into first grade
and then uh you're envisioning and then
they're going to come out of high school
12 years later
and you've already pre-planned now what
they're gonna learn when you're not even
sure if there's going to be any world
left to come out to like
clearly you need to have a much more
opportunistic education system that
keeps adapting itself very rapidly as
Society re-adapts the the skills that
were really useful when the curriculum
was written I mean how many of those
skills are going to get you a job in 12
years I mean seriously if we just Linger
on the gpt4 system a little bit
you kind of hinted at it especially
talking about the importance of
Consciousness in um in the human mind
with homosexions
do you think gpt4
is conscious
I love this question
so let's define consciousness first
because in my experience like 90 of all
arguments about Consciousness or land to
the two people arguing having totally
different definitions of what it is then
they're just shouting past each other
I define consciousness
as subjective experience
right now I'm experiencing colors and
sounds and emotions you know
but does a self-driving car experience
anything
that's the question about whether it's
conscious or not right
other people think you should Define
consciousness differently
fine by me but then maybe use a
different word for it or they can I'm
going to use Consciousness for this at
least
um
so um
but if people hate that yeah so
is gpt4 conscious does GPT 4 have
subjective experience
short answer I don't know
because we still don't know what it is
that gives this wonderful subjective
experience
that is kind of the meaning of our life
right because meaning itself the feeling
of meaning is a subjective experience
Joy is a subjective experience love is a
subjective experience
we don't know what it is
I've written some papers about this a
lot of people have
Julio tononi Professor has
stuck his neck out the farthest and
written down actually very bold
mathematical
conjecture for what's the essence of
conscious information processing he
might be wrong he might be right
we should test it
he postulates that his Consciousness has
to do with loops in the information
processing so our brain has loops
information can go around and around in
in computer science nerdspeak you call
it a recurrent neural network where some
of the output gets fed back in again
and with his
mathematical formalism if it's a
feed-forward neural network where
information only goes in One Direction
like from your eye retina into the back
of your brain for example that's not
conscious so he would predict that your
retina itself isn't conscious of
anything
or a video camera now the interesting
thing about gpt4 is it's also one way
flow of information so if tanoni is
right and gpt4 is a very intelligent
zombie they can do all this smart stuff
but isn't experiencing anything
and this is
both a relief in that you don't have if
it's true you know in that you don't
have to feel guilty about turning off
gpt4 and wiping its memory whenever a
new user comes along
I wouldn't like it when you did that to
me neuralized me like in Men In Black
but it's also
creepy that you can have very high
intelligence perhaps then it's not
conscious because if we get replaced by
machines
and why is it sad enough that Humanity
isn't here anymore because I kind of
like Humanity
but at least if the machines were
conscious they could be like well but
they are descendants and maybe we they
have our values and they're our children
but if if tenoni is right and it's all
these are all
trans Transformers that are
not in the sense of the of Hollywood but
in the sense of these one-way Direction
and they're all that works so they're
all the zombies that's the Ultimate
Zombie Apocalypse Now we have this
universe that goes on with great
construction projects and stuff but
there's no one experiencing anything
that would be like
the ultimate depressing future so I
actually think uh
as we move forward to the building more
advanced AI
you should do more research on figuring
out what kind of information processing
actually has experience because I think
that's what it's all about and I
completely don't buy
the dismissal that some people some
people will say well this is all
because Consciousness equals
intelligence right it's obviously not
true you can have a lot of conscious
experience when you're not really
accomplishing any goals at all you're
just reflecting on something and you can
sometimes um
have things doing things that are quite
intelligence probably without being
being conscious but I also worry that we
humans won't
will discriminate against AI systems
that clearly exhibit Consciousness that
we will not allow AI systems
self-consciousness we'll come up with
theories
about measuring Consciousness that will
say this is a lesser being and this was
like I worry about that because maybe we
humans will create something that is
better than us humans in the in the way
that we find beautiful which is the they
cut they have a deeper subjective
experience of reality not only are they
smarter but they feel deeper and we
humans will hate them for it
as we as human history has shown they'll
be the other we'll try to suppress it
it'll create conflict it'll create War
all of this I I worry about this too are
you saying that we humans sometimes come
up with self-serving arguments no we
would never do that would we well that's
the danger here is uh even in this early
stages we might create something
beautiful yeah and uh will erase its
memory I I uh
was horrified as a kid when someone
started boiling uh boiling lobsters like
to my God that that's so cruel and some
grown-up there that back in Sweden said
oh it doesn't feel pain I'm like how do
you know that oh scientists have shown
that
and then there was a recent study where
they showed that lobsters actually do
feel pain
when you boil them so they banned
Lobster boiling in Switzerland now you
have to kill them in a different way
first
presumably scientific research boil down
to someone asked the lobster does this
hurt
survey so we do the same thing with
cruelty to farm animals also all these
self-serving Arguments for why they're
fine and yeah so we should certainly
watchful I think step one is just be
humble and acknowledge that
Consciousness is not the same thing as
intelligence
and I believe that Consciousness still
is a form of information processing
where it's really information being
aware of itself in a certain way and
let's study it and give ourselves a
little bit of time and I think we will
be able to figure out actually what it
is
that causes Consciousness and then we
can make probably unconscious robots
that do the boring jobs that we would
feel or immoral to give the machines but
if you have a companion robot taking
care of your mom
or something like that she would
probably want it to be conscious right
so the emotions it seems to display
aren't fake
all these things can be
done in a good way if we give ourselves
a little bit of time and don't run and
take on this challenge is there
something you could say to the timeline
that you think about uh about the
development of AGI
depending on the day I'm sure that
changes for you but
when do you think there'll be a really
big leap in intelligence where it would
definitively say we have built AGI do
you think it's one year from now five
years from now 10 20 50.
what's Your Gut say
honestly
for the past decade I've deliberately
given very long timelines because I
didn't want to fuel some kind of stupid
Morlock race yeah but I think that cat
has really left the bag now
uh I I think you might be very very
close
I I don't think that Microsoft paper is
totally off when they say that there are
some glimmers of AJ is not AGI yet
it's not an agent there's a lot of
things you can't do but um
I wouldn't bet very strongly against it
happening
very soon that's why we decided to do
this open letter because you know if
there's ever been a time to pause
you know it's today
there's a feeling like this gpt4 is a
big transition into waking everybody up
to uh the effectiveness of these systems
yeah and so the next version
will be big yeah and if that next one
isn't AGI maybe the next next one will
and there are many companies trying to
do these things
um basic architecture of them is not
some sort of super well kept secret so
this is this is the time to um
a lot of people have said for many years
that there will come a time when we want
to pause a little bit
that time is now